[Music]
welcome back in the house you South
Korea we're standing a few feet from the
DMZ the Demilitarized Zone where the
president met with Kim jong-un on Sunday
back in the United States the president
just kicked off his reelection campaign
with the slogan keep America great
greater not though America still has
quite a few problems homelessness is a
huge one so is the opioid epidemic and
big tech and it's strangulation of some
of our most basic freedoms the president
have to address those problems if he
wants to win reelection and we asked him
about all of them in part two of our
interview here it is Google by some
measures the most powerful company in
the world all information flows through
it they're against you they don't want
you re-elected can you get re-elected if
Google's against you so you know I've
been hearing that about Google and
Facebook and dinner that's right I won
they were totally against me I want
Hillary didn't think you were gonna win
well they fought me very hard I mean I
heard that and they're fighting me hard
right now which is incredible because I
think the Democrats want to shut them up
and frankly so do a lot of the
Republicans want to shut them up if you
look at Twitter I have millions and
millions of people on Twitter and it's
you know it's a very good arm from it's
great social media but they don't treat
me right and I know for a fact I mean a
lot of people try and follow me and it's
very hard I have so many people coming
up that they say sir it's so hard they
make it hard to follow what they're
doing is wrong and possibly illegal and
a lot of things are being looked at
right now but you're right Google is
very powerful but I won and a poll just
came out today I'm at 54 or 55 and they
do say you can add 10 to whatever poll I
have okay and I never get good press I
mean I haven't had a good story I used
to get the best press of the world you
remember the old days when I was an
entrepreneur represent and nobody's ever
had to think 93% I came out the other
day 93% and I'm talking about series it
should be good they make them bad or
should be great they make them like
neutral and yet I won and I'll win again
so when they say it's the most powerful
it may be but they were against
Facebook was against me they were all
against me
Twitter was against me Twitter's I've
been very good for Twitter I don't think
Twitter would be the same without what I
do on Twitter but they just have this
crazy disposition to have this
philosophy and yet the Democrats are
very much opposed to them in so many
ways it's sort of an amazing thing so
you just said that what the tech
companies are doing maybe illegal is
there a role for the Justice Department
well I could be and I don't want to even
say whether or not they're doing
something but I will tell you there are
a lot of people that want us to and
there are a lot of people all you have
to do is pick up a newspaper and read it
or see it or watch Fox or what some
other network there are a lot of people
that want us to take action against
Facebook and against Twitter and frankly
against Amazon yep
Amazon also a lot of people want us to
take action are you going to I can't say
that you come to where we are now Asaka
or tokyo and the cities are clean
there's no graffiti no one going the
bathroom on the street you don't see
just very very different from our city
yep well there's no some of us in some
of our cities but in New York City San
Francisco Los Angeles they've got a
major problem with thirst with filth
why is that it's a phenomena that
started two years ago it's disgraceful
I'm gonna maybe and I'm looking at it
very seriously we're doing some other
things you probably noticed like some of
the very important things that we're
doing now but we're looking at it very
seriously because you can't do that you
can't have what's happening where police
officers are getting sick just by
walking the beat I mean they're getting
actually very sick where people are
getting sick where the people living
there are living in hell too although
some of them have mental problems where
they don't even know they're living that
way in fact perhaps they like living
that way they can't do that
you cannot ruin our cities and you have
people that work in those cities they
work in office buildings and to get into
the building they have to walk through a
scene that nobody would have believed
possible three years ago and this is the
liberal establishment this is what I'm
fighting they I
know if they're afraid of votes I don't
know if they really believe that this
should be taking place but it's a
terrible thing that's taking place and
we may be you know I had a situation
when I first became president we had
certain areas of Washington DC where
that was starting to happen and I ended
it very quickly I said you can't do that
when we have leaders of the world coming
in to see the President of the United
States and they're writing down a
highway
they can't be looking at that I really
believe that it hurts our country they
can't be looking it seems like you see
in Los Angeles in San Francisco San
Francisco I own property in San
Francisco so I don't care except it was
so beautiful and now areas that you used
to think as being you know really
something very special you take a look
at what's going on with San Francisco
it's terrible so we're looking at it
very serious that we may intercede we
may do something to get that whole thing
cleaned up it's inappropriate no we have
to take the people and do something we
have to do something right and you know
we're really not very equipped as a
government to be doing that kind of work
that's not really the kind of work that
the government probably should be doing
we've never had this in our lives before
in our country and it's not only those
few cities it's a couple of others at
the same time most of our cities are
doing great but if you look at some of
these they usually sanctuary cities run
by very liberal people and the states
are run by very liberal people but the
thing that nobody can figure out is do
these governor's or mayor's do they
really think this is a positive do they
really think this is okay cuz it's not
it's destroying their city and it's
destroying a whole way of life and it's
not our country it's not what our
country is all about we have still more
of that interview with the president we
asked him later in that hour about UFOs
we'll tell you what he said Friday
during a special edition of this show